here we go
should be going live now
see how we get here here
we go all right my friend we are live
i'm going to tweet this out real quick
so we get some people in here how are
you
very well very well excellent happy to
be here talking with you
absolutely all right as we wait for uh
for people to kind of come in here let's
um
let's wait a minute or two for those of
you that are
watching this afterwards please please
please
smash the like button and subscribe to
the channel so that more people see this
uh here come people they're starting to
stream in let us know in the comments
where you guys
are tuning in from diego where are you
well i'm in buenos aires currently to
the pandemic
due to the pandemic i've been locked for
for many months so i think we have the
longest
lock in in history
uh let's see tennessee ut sports of
course
uh let's see where everybody else is
coming in from uh
somebody said i played football at
cornell and beat up on the bison every
year okay rush relax
uh let's just pray from florida
iowa vienna philippines u.s connecticut
paris new york tijuana london edmonton
louisiana tennessee california oakland
beaumont maine ireland where else you
guys coming from prague new york
havana wales florida new jersey
houston san diego philippines tijuana
all right there's a bunch of you guys in
here
cracking um here's what we're gonna do i
see brazil
uh what else uh massachusetts croatia st
louis cleveland i love it all right make
sure you guys smash the like button
uh or the thumbs up make sure you
subscribe to the channel uh diego thank
you so much for doing this i think we're
gonna have a lot of fun today
um let's just get started first with uh
who you are and kind of your story
before you started to build this
decentralized infrastructure for bitcoin
well i mean my my story with technology
goes back to the web days
my story with social
activism goes back to when i was very
young i started doing social activism
with my
my mother in the slums of buenos aires
when i was nine
and i was always trying to there's two
things that are
commonplace in my in my life it's like
trying to transform society and then
using technology
to do that and when i was 20 i
created a website for the main newspaper
in argentina
back then it had a million subscribers
and it was one of the top websites
for latin america for many years so i in
1995 i started with that and i leave the
whole
web the dot-com you know boom and
and what was the foundations of the web
that we lived today
uh so that's how i started with
technology and i
oh and my view or my objective was
exactly that seeing how we could could
use technology
to create a more egalitarian or
you know society empower individuals and
and then when i
got uh in touch with bitcoin in 2012
uh for me it was evident this was the
second wave
of that disruption that started with the
web and
bitcoin was taking that disruption from
information communications into a
financial system
so i started building communities in
latin america first in argentina and
then helping
build communities in all latin america
um
and in that process at the end of 2013
i i started doing some experiments early
2014
uh bringing this technology bringing
bitcoin into the slums and
and doing experiments in the meet ups
and everything and then i realized
um in order to to fulfill the
the full vision of like bitcoin becoming
the infrastructure of the future we
needed to extend bitcoin
with other protocols to to become that
and and then
we got together with the with the
original founders of of rsk
at the end of 2015 and and we started
doing that
extending bitcoin to become the
financial system of the future
so let's talk a little bit about when
you first came across bitcoin it was
very early for most people
uh what was kind of your reaction to it
and kind of why did you gravitate so
much towards hey this is going to be
something that i want to spend a lot of
my time working on
well you know the the first contact i
had with bitcoin was in 2011 but i
didn't get it
so it took me like another year and a
and a call from wences casares one of my
good friends from the web days
uh to really reconnect with with bitcoin
and what happened to me is that back
then we had capital controls in
argentina we have capital controls again
now
but it was almost impossible to get
money in and out
of argentina and i had a web development
company back then and
and it took me like a month to get the
money from my customers abroad
from europe and the u.s into argentina
and i was losing 10 percent of the money
in that process and when says he was in
the silicon valley he told me
the ito opened an account in blockchain
info i did
and he sent me like 5 5000 bitcoins back
then it was like
maybe 50k usd and
and i sent them back minus one he left
me one to play around with it which
which i lost in satoshi dice so
you know and and then the whole thing
happened within an hour
and we didn't have to ask permission to
anybody for doing that so
then i realized okay this is how a truly
open
and inclusive financial system should
look like it's like this is like
truly where the finance the financial
system should go
and and then that was like after that i
was like 15 days
reading about bitcoin no no not sleeping
much
and and the first thing i was like
reading about was more about the
monetary systems i read the history of
money
uh how the monetary systems of the world
work
how the financial system work um and at
the end of that i realized bitcoin was a
solution for something i was looking for
many many years for more than a decade
that was a way of creating
self-organized societies and
peer-to-peer
organizations so so then i i went to my
partners
in the software factory and told them
i'm sorry but
i'm going to develop my life to this and
and the rest is history that's when i
started doing everything there was to it
no like
mining with a gpu computer meeting in
cafes in buenos aires to buy and sell
bitcoins
um starting doing meet ups the early
meetups in argentina and then in other
countries in latin america
so that that was my early connection
with bitcoin
it's an absolutely incredible kind of
journey you've been on let's talk a
little bit about iov labs and kind of
what you're doing today so what was the
genesis of the idea to start the
business and then we'll get to rsk in a
minute
yes i mean iob labs has started us irs
rsk you know so we we first started with
this idea of
uh at the end of 2015 of
extending bitcoin to to have a second
layer as a settlement
using the bitcoin infrastructure and the
bitcoin currency
to power uh an agreement settlement
layer what
usually people call smart contracts uh
so so so we we started with that idea
but then
over the process we realized that you
know we needed other layers on top
to scale payments to solve user
interactions like having name services
or aliases
uh have secure ways of restoring data
that's when we came out with the idea of
of the rsk infrastructure framework on
top of rsk
and and that's when you know we changed
the name from our skate to iov labs
which
comes from internet of value labs
because we think what we are doing is
creating multiple layers on top of
bitcoin to create
the internet of value so so that's
exactly what we are doing at iov labs
making this internet of value a reality
and
building uh you know everything with
bitcoin as the foundations
of that internet of value let's talk a
little bit about
um kind of there's two worlds that seem
to be being built right now right
there's the bitcoin world where
bitcoin is at the center you're
obviously building a lot of
decentralized infrastructure
um and kind of trying to take bitcoin
from
just a single currency kind of store
value medium of exchange
and really building an entire financial
system around bitcoin
and then there's another world which is
the kind of ethereum type world
where people are building decentralized
finance and there's a lot of
experimentation and innovation
i think that you and i see pretty
eye-to-eye in terms of
both of those worlds have a importance
and they serve different purposes
so maybe talk let's start with the
ethereum world and kind of what many
people are now calling decentralized
finance
but this is everything from
decentralized exchanges to lending
protocols and kind of all the things
that are happening in that ethereum
world
how do you view that uh kind of
ecosystem and its importance for
uh the overall development of this
industry
well i think it's uh you know when when
we started
with rsk actually we were aware of the
of the ethereum project it was not live
yet
but you know i was in the north american
bitcoin conference in january 2014 and
and i saw the vitalik pitch when he
presented smart contracts and everything
but in my mind
um i mean the idea was great but
i thought that pulling up a new network
a new infrastructure network and
more importantly creating the level of
liquidity and the
network effects that bitcoin had
achieved in a completely new network
would take many many years
and so for me the shortest and safest
path
in the long term was to build all those
things on top of
of the bitcoin infrastructure and the
bitcoin currency
um and and to be honest i think ethereum
did an amazing job they
they like got to a point of maturity
although that now they have these big
bottlenecks in terms of
scalability and some congestion
due to the success they have no but they
they push it to a level that i wouldn't
imagine
when we started i thought it was going
to take them much much
more time and so i think ethereum did
a great contribution in terms of
experimentation of protocols and things
but also it it's the big theme of its
own success
because now the bottlenecks they have
will
will leave them to have to change the
core elements of
of their platform and and more important
the economic incentive model and the
actor so
so they are in in a crossroads where
they need to
you know leave behind people who was the
early supporters of the crypt economy of
ethereum
uh and moving to a system that can scale
properly
um so so i i see some uncertainty
but definitely the developers community
they build
all the technology they build is amazing
and and we leverage on that
indeed we took the evm uh from ethereum
and
and rsk is using that evm
then the consensus protocol is not
exactly the same it's all
the the consensus protocol from rs case
one called decor plus
that solves some of the consensus
problems consensus protocol problems of
the ethereum
which is ghost so we did innovation
where we thought
innovation uh was needed but we also
capture all the value from the ethereum
community and i think
the going to the point of defy i think
defy
you know decentralized finance is
actually the the ultimate goal
i think the first decentralized finance
protocol is bitcoin
and and the ultimate goal is to provide
all the financial services that today
exist in centralized models
to provide them in a peer-to-peer
decentralized fashion so
i'm you know fully in line with the
objectives of ethereum
maybe the main difference is i think the
bot the the bottom layer
should be bitcoin because you need a
store of value that is
as censorship resistant as neutral as
possible
and i think bitcoin is that you know
that scarcity that
digital gold model is what makes bitcoin
the best
store of value you can have so so
foundations are very
important for for this new financial
system that we are building
so is it fair to say that um what you're
building
is decentralized finance the way that
you're pursuing that
is to use bitcoin as the core unit of
account and then
infrastructure around bitcoin is
decentralized in nature
and the ethereum community is saying
we're going to build decentralized
finance they're choosing to build
decentralized infrastructure as well but
they're building it around
eth as kind of their core unit of
account
and really the two differences in that
argument that you're making and i tend
to agree with you
if this is what you're saying is one
bitcoin is
digital application of sound money eth
is not
and then also there is a difference
between the security
the decentralization um and kind of the
um you know really that the testing of
the censorship
uh or non-censorship of the bitcoin
layer versus the ethereum layer is that
fair to say like that's the two
differences that you see but ultimately
the kind of the finish line or the goal
of both of these communities
is the same i think you are completely
right
i mean our goals are exactly the same
our strategies our tactics are are
different
but conceptually we want and and we have
made some contributions that
ethereum is taking sergio has pointed
out sergey is our chief scientist
co-founder of rsk
he has pointed out some you know he has
participated in some of the ethereum
debates and contributed things so
we think that from a technology
perspective we are contributing to the
same
things there's one subtle thing
that i think it's a but very important
thing in the long term
is that by securing rsk
via merge mining that means that the
same bitcoin miners with the same
infrastructure they have they don't
have to change anything of the
infrastructure because by by securing
both networks rsk
and bitcoin with the same miners and
creating incentives in the
same token rsk becomes part of the
crypto economy of of bitcoin so
there's no conflict between rsk and and
bitcoin because we are contributing both
networks are contributing to the same
infrastructure
uh you know security infrastructure and
also contributing to the same
base currency and that's essential
because if you were to use
you know bitcoin wrapped bitcoins on
ethereum then you have a conflict
because basically you are
helping bitcoin adoption but on the
underlying layer
you are also you know with all that
economic activity you are incentivizing
a competing network
so so at the in the maybe in this moment
is not
important but in the long term those
conflicts
having two conflicting security
infrastructures
will create tension and that might be
like i said so i think that's the other
that's why i think
although in the short term we are in
equal terms and we are
aiming for the same things in the long
term rsk is
an important protection layer for the
bitcoin economy
and infrastructure absolutely before we
move on everyone who is
watching live right now please make sure
that you smash the like button so that
more people on youtube will see this
feel free to share the link on twitter
reddit or wherever else let's get more
people paying attention to this
uh diego let's talk a little bit about
kind of where you see this going
so if we zoom out and we look ahead 10
or 20 years
is this a world where bitcoin is the
core unit of account it
kind of ascends to global reserve status
and all of the infrastructure is
completely decentralized and it's built
around bitcoin
like what is your vision for a decade or
two out in the future
i think maybe decay is too short for the
process we are
we are leaving i think you know if you
look at the web it started in
late 80s early 90s and it took the web
at least 20 years to to become like
commonplace and
and you know what we know today
uh i i think bitcoin yeah maybe your
right is
is one decade more from here um
but conceptually i think diversity
is is important for anti-fragility so i
don't think there will be like a single
network to
to rule them all i think we will have
multiple networks with different
security models and that's what we have
today is like
you know bitcoin is maximized for
security
and there's trade-offs in terms of
scalability and functionality because of
that
then you know rsk is choosing to share
the security infrastructure but there's
also trade-off i mean it's
is adding more functionality ethereum
has a separate infrastructure what i
will
what i do see is i think for each
security model
there will be a winner so let's say that
bitcoin is proof of work based on shot
to 256 uh ethereum is based on keycard
uh so it's different you know you will
have asic
or specialized hardware for each one of
the protocols
maybe litecoin and dodge coin are like
another
infrastructure model or security then
you have all the pos
models so i think there will be a
winning
you know network in each one of these
security models and they will all
evolve i don't see one like overriding
the whole thing i think one will be and
you can see that in bitcoin today
you know one will be the big dominant we
will have kind of a pareto scene
so you have 2 one dominating 80
of the of the value transactions and
everything i think that's bitcoin
and then you will have 20 that will be
distributed among the long tail of
different security models that will be
suitable for other use cases
because pos very very likely is very
good if you are only are handling
i know economies with 50 000 people and
a few
tens tens of millions of dollars but
it's not good if you want to have the
reserve value of the world
so i don't think we will have like one
dominant network
that's why i talk about the internet of
value it's a network of networks
and with different you know delegation
of responsibilities different security
models that are suitable for different
use cases but if you
talk about reserve of value then it's
bitcoin there's nothing else there
got it and so when you think about kind
of the steps needed to go from where we
are today to that vision that you're
describing
what are you building right now in terms
of the actual
products and then what are the other
things that need to be built to get us
there
well we are mostly focused on
infrastructure
so there are other the pioneers of rsk
are building the products on top of
and the solutions on top of the
infrastructure we build
so our focus is mostly on on i would say
three
elements interoperability because this
is like
we need to have trustless transfer of
value between these different networks
and and again i think that's important
for anti-fragility of the ecosystem as a
whole
if you have one network to attack then
you know
it's easier to shut down the whole
movement but if you have multiple
networks with different security models
different actors
properly interconnected seamlessly
interconnected
attacking and killing one network
doesn't kill the whole phenomenon so
so you anti-fragility interconnectivity
and
and trust minimize interconnectivity
between blockchains and networks is
is key for the long-term success of the
movement of the decentralization
movement
so that's one thing and we have already
created
the safest uh to a bridge
between two blockchains that is the one
between bitcoin and rsk
and we also have a two apec bridge with
ethereum so we have interconnected the
the two main uh crypt economies
so that's one thing the other thing is
scalability and it's leveraging
is not only our research we are
leveraging on the research that
you know lining has done on payment
channels
um now we are working on enveloping that
is an abstraction protocol that enables
users to use a single token
and pay the network fees in the same
token although the miners always in the
case of rsk get bitcoin but
you know abstracting the the users from
the complexities
of the of the economic models of the
underlying
networks and also other things that are
important for mass adoption that has to
do with
uh the the user friendliness of the
interactions and
and what i would say is in 2021
all the protocols needed for the crypto
systems to work exactly as a fintech
exactly as
the traditional banking solutions but in
a decentralized environment
are here so 2021 is a year where all
these
technologies that was you were asking
what i think needs to happen that's like
the first thing was that
we needed to be able to offer users the
same level of experience as a of a bank
or a fintech and finally we are there
all the protocols and technology to
scale to
give user-friendly experiences are there
so now it's uh it's a matter of making
all those components converge
the following step is how i see this is
like we are building this new
infrastructure that will be the
infrastructure of the future the
financial infrastructure
of the future but the money lives on the
traditional financial infrastructure
that is based on on legal contracts we
are based on
on protocols programming you know uh
agreeing programmable agreements the
traditional model is based on legal
agreements and and basically what what
we
what needs to happen is we need to
interconnect both
the new the future infrastructure the
legacy infrastructure
and start translating the the value from
one to the other and that's what's
happening now
so the other challenge we have is how we
create these flows between the
traditional financial system into this
new financial system
and and then how we retain those flows
how we
prove this new financial system is is
better is more efficient
is more open it's more respectful of
your privacy of your
of the individuals and in between that
what we'll have and i think it's part of
what's coming because we are
we are entering the mass adult adoption
um moment of crypto in between what will
happen is
regulators will come with all their full
force because
basically they are losing control i mean
we are moving from
nation state design financial systems
into glo into a truly global financial
system and that's a direct attack
to the to the power of the nation state
i mean
it's breaking up state and money you
know
so so i think that's what's coming let
me ask you this question so when you're
talking about kind of a legacy financial
system
and building those bridges to have a um
kind of transition or a flow of funds
from the traditional system into this
kind of decentralized digital uh what
many would consider an alternative
financial system today
what is the biggest obstacle there is it
that the technology is
not built yet is it an education thing
is it just a familiarity like like what
is the biggest
obstacle in the moment to go from legacy
world
into the new decentralized digital
financial system
i i think for a long time i think there
was a missing link
and the missing link was stable
coins what is now called stereo coins no
because i think you are asking people to
many people is you are asking them to do
one
leap of faith and and coming to a new
financial infrastructure
and at the same time that you you are
asking them to do that
you're asking them to start using a new
asset
that is not familiar for them so if you
want stable coins are the
the gateway drug to the crypto world no
so
now you can you what what is happening
is now we we have that asset that people
can relate to
you have a dollar or a euro digital euro
so it's different infrastructure same
assets that you already know
and then you start questioning yourself
and saying okay but
then we have bitcoin and and we have you
know
well of course the bitcoin price going
up is a good
adoption driver because then people
start thinking about it and then
you know you fall into the rabbit hole
because that's what happens to everybody
that
that gets into it he's like the first
thing is you come for the price
uh rise or appreciation and then you
stay for
for for the all the educational process
that implies
questioning how the financial system of
the world works so
i think all the things are in place we
just need those things to material
the most the biggest friction will have
is regulators like you know creating
more
and more uh friction in the coming years
on the frontier between the
local financial systems and this global
financial system
and that that happens with any
innovation wave
skype was without regulation for 10 12
years
and disrupted every regulation existing
in telecommunications in global
international telecommunications
and what is happening now is the same
but in the financial world so
that i think is what's happening i don't
think there's any any
missing piece now i think the pieces are
there but we will see more and more
resistance from the start to school
to this movement because this will
change who are the incumbents and the
people in power
do you feel like um when the regulators
kind of turn
and say hey this is you know not
something that we
enjoy or like uh is it something where
50
of regulators will try to embrace it and
50 will try to fight it
is it something where majority are going
to try to fight it but they don't really
have
an ability to fight it because it's
decentralized and and kind of there's
nothing they can do
like how do you see that playing out
with regulators in terms of who embraces
who fights it
and then how effective the people who
fight it can actually be
i think it's a matter of opportunity if
you are a small jurisdiction
and and given the the situation of the
global
financial system you have more to win
than to lose
now we are seeing for example in the
caribbean the banks are
unbanking middle-class people just
because they want to do the risking
so that that's the place where you have
the opportunities where you say
you know um well i
i i mean for me as a small jurisdiction
this is the opportunity
to join a global economy to start doing
agreements with other countries and and
have a unified front and
you know and have access to things that
the global the traditional global
financial system is not offering me
i'm not sitting on the table of the
global conversation
for big economies that are the ones
dominating
the the global economy this is a threat
so
i think it's more about the
opportunities and and threats than
than about percentages i would say all
the big
economies dominant economies in the
world
will pose the the biggest resistance
and the smallest will the smallers will
join
uh faster because they they see an
opportunity of joining
this innovation and and becoming
relevant in what's
the future of finance got it and do you
feel like
it's fair to say that um out of the
incumbent financial firms
some will get disrupted by a lot of this
and some will
kind of adapt and end up actually
embracing it and we'll see
um you know i don't know goldman sachs
or jp morgan or whoever
end up actually just interacting with
the protocols just like the challengers
or startups are today
but how do you see the incumbents
responding to the rise
and adoption of you know kind of a
decentralized infrastructure
around bitcoin
i think it's a matter of how vested you
are on something
i i've seen people that that started
with
what for them were small investments
that became
like a very relevant part of their
portfolio
and and some of them decided to support
core developers uh you know start
because
if you are smart and then and you have a
lot of your assets
on on you know uh bested on
on a particular platform you know that
having your own eyes
into the platform development in in
keeping the the
the platform honest uh you know makes
sense so i think it's
at the end it's about more it's like the
moment goldman sachs
starts like having a substantial part of
their assets or
not the substantial but important enough
uh part of their assets in the networks
they will become part of the
infrastructure
that's how it works it's like you know
it happens with the with the exchanges
if you are an exchange in bitcoin
you you're not going to to run your
you know your bitcoin node on a cloud
server or hire a third-party service
because that's like a
weakness in your infrastructure you're
putting your money at risk
but but also there's like a process of
understanding this it's like
there's an educational element to it
because you need to understand that you
are playing a different game
you know in a decentralized network and
in traditional
you know because again the the
engagement model and the security models
of traditional
of centralized systems is based on
insurance
legal contracts so it's a different
mindset here is you
the famous don't trust verify moto is
what drives everything
so so i think there will be some clashes
there in terms of of understanding these
new models
absolutely uh before we get into q a
i've got one more uh
question for you but uh if you're
watching the live stream right now make
sure that you
smash the thumbs up the like button so
more people
on youtube can see this take the url go
share it on twitter
reddit or wherever else and then if you
have questions for diego drop them in
the chat here i'm looking at it
and i would try to over the next 30
minutes or so ask him as many of them as
possible
and if you stump him then good for you
but probably not
uh one last question before we get into
the q a is
um tell us more about the actual like
rif
infrastructure that you have um and kind
of the rsk
uh and iov products in terms of when you
spend your day building what are you
guys building
uh and for those that don't know
anything about the business kind of give
us just a
layman term overview of the business
well you know i that's the thing iov
labs is the sponsor of an ecosystem it's
like the the first mover of an ecosystem
we build the protocols
but the people building the solutions
are entrepreneurs that are building
you know solutions on top of the
infrastructure we build
so from a infrastructure perspective you
know we
we first created the rsk blockchain
that's open source
is into the hands of the community and
indeed we don't have a control on the
network anymore it's like
you know we like anything it starts like
uh
centralized bitcoin started with satoshi
then halfini
join and then you know you you started
moving from centralized to decentralized
and rsk now is fairly decentralized we
have no control on the network behavior
we only
keep developing the protocol and
proposing things
improvements to the protocol and and
more and more the other participants in
the network are the ones taking over
new improvements and so that's one thing
on on top of the rsk blockchain what you
have is all the d5 for bitcoin movement
that is starting so
you have money on chain that created the
first stable asset
dollar on chain um token uh
asset backed by bitcoin which is great
because it's
it doesn't depend on intermediaries you
you you have dollar and chains you can
go to the protocol
and get whatever amount of bitcoin
that dollar is worth at that moment so
so you have kind of going to the
back to the gold standard but being
bitcoin the
the gold the reserve asset so i think
that's that's great it's a truly
peer-to-peer monetary system
and on top of that you have a team that
created rsk swap that is the equivalent
of uni-swap where you can
you know you have a decentralized
exchange and an automated market making
protocol
and then you have sovereign that is
bringing lending
uh and and margin trading other
protocols from ethereum are coming
like avi even the dye protocol is
bringing dye
into our skates so you have all this
open finance ecosystem
where we have the pioneers already there
um
you have wallet providers the fine and
big so all the ones
then you have people connecting with the
real economy you have the x-rate for
example
that is connecting like the logistics
business
into this financial system is creating
you know
um for example factoring for truck
drivers in the us
so so you have like that connection with
the real economy and optimizing the
logistic industry
then you have coi banks that is like
connecting
uh you know the banks and financial
institutions of
latin america and using these open
financial networks a network
as a backbone to interconnect countries
that don't connect well among them
then you have group of sara helping the
gas and oil industry and go over working
with governments to implement this on
system so
it's you know it's an ecosystem so our
purpose and our success is that
these people building these solutions is
successful and and we help them that's
our business if you want we are
not you know a purpose-driven
organization what we want is to create a
financial system that
will be inclusive by design and and will
be able to
to serve any human being on the planet
regardless
of their current financial condition
and on the rift part uh as i said is
what we did is we supplement this
smart contract layer and the bitcoin
store value
with peer-to-peer protocols then now
with the
you know the platform the platforming
that we are seeing
in twitter in many places this is
becoming more and more relevant so
what we did is we built protocols for
secure peer-to-peer communications
protocols for decentralized storage
naming services decentralized naming
services
so we can we can build truly
peer-to-peer applications secure
by you know decentralized smart contract
platforms and a decentralized economy so
the reef marketplace is a is that it's a
truly open
sharing economy engine where all these
protocols where anybody can be
a consumer of these protocols or a
provider of this protocol so
that's what we are doing like you know
taking decentralization all the way up
from bitcoin
to business logic into the internet
peer-to-peer protocol so that's a little
bit of
well not a living a
one more question but i have one more
before we go to the q a is uh you're
outside the united states
and uh you're in south america um help
people understand if they live in the
united states what is the
current kind of sentiment and uh and
maybe the benefits
of bitcoin to you know countries uh
abroad versus maybe in the united states
where the dollar and the financial
system
uh works really well that that's very
interesting
it's a very good question because you
know i've been roaming around the world
for
four years before the pandemic visiting
asia
europe the us latin america and
and what you see is that in emerging in
the emerging world you don't have to
explain why bitcoin is relevant
because our economies the economies in
latin america
has such instability and and and well
you have capital controls
hyperinflation uh you know
corruption so everything
around you is unstable you you don't
have any place to
to protect your value and people is
hatching
against the the measures of the
government
all the time so for for in that context
even for people who is like thinking
short term if you have 50
inflation per year or in cases like
venezuela you are talking about
thousands
of percentage of inflation per year then
then bitcoin is a is a store of value
and is is a hardware
you know a safe hardware for for your
value
and and it's a safe hardware that has
global connectivity
that that you can like with your value
connect with anybody in the world so you
can pay
anybody in the world you can get paid
from anywhere in the world and that's
what happened in venezuela for example
where
a lot of freelancers are working and
getting paid in bitcoin
we have people in argentina sending
money back using dollar and chain
to their families in venezuela using
these networks because the traditional
system
you know gets a 10 cut you know and
so so in the emerging world in
in most of the economies in the world i
would say
you know bitcoin is a necessity it's not
an option then you have of course
the top percent of the population which
we are part of that can
save money for two or three years like
that have a longer horizon financial
horizon and then
we see bitcoin also as a store of value
a mid to long term store value
but it's interesting to understand that
other side of bitcoin that is not
only only for mid to long-term storage
value
yeah there's a bunch of questions that
we got so we're going to go through
these i'm going to just
yell them out and you give me the
answers as as you get them and we'll go
until we're tired of answering questions
uh let's start
with uh are you going to add more
wallets in the future
yeah absolutely we we we help
you know wallets uh i i think we have
been working with
edge wallet which is a very nice
bitcoiner wallet and
and we have been adding some in asia
like math wallet
so we keep helping wallet providers
integrate the technology and we have a
reference wallet that is their wallet
that it's an open source water that we
use as a as a codeway so
we we help others build uh solutions
using the open open source base that is
for android and
and and also for ios so so
yeah definitely and if you know a wallet
of
preference please share it and then we
will try to contact them and help them
integrate uh your thoughts on adoption
of
crypto in india the supreme court there
has lifted the ban on crypto in 2020
any thoughts on india specifically yes
uh absolutely uh you know i
i'm very good friend with sunny
ray and then he was at the at the center
of that dispute they
they actually won unocoin won the
the the trial with the rbi the
central bank of india where they tried
to
you know by force shut down the crypto
activities and they won and
and i think they they did a great
service to the crypto community
and i think india is although i'm not an
expert
we should bring sunny for that but but
sunny ray and
um you know india has a long tradition
of
um you know protecting value
in with gold and you know the government
has been trying to to
break that you know for building you
know gold store
store of value and so i think india is a
very interesting place because
culturally they have been already
hatching for
i would say thousands of years in
in in hard money in long-term money
as i like to call it uh so for them for
them bitcoin is a
and also the technology you know
adoption is is huge so mobile adoption
is huge so
i think they are ripe for disruption
there so i think
i have big hopes in india and also it's
becoming
india already has the same size of as
population as china and he's becoming
the production center he's
replacing china as the production center
so
for for the world in many aspects so i
think you know
yeah india will be a very very
interesting
[Music]
environment uh what can i do in the
bitcoin space besides
coding and there's a bunch of people
asking about uh where they should look
for jobs and all that kind of stuff but
but how do you think about
uh what people can do besides coding in
the bitcoin space
well i think education is a great place
to eat there's a lot of people willing
to educate it
from very you know every time we have
these new waves of
price increase and adoption because they
come
hand in hand a lot of people ask for
help
you know uh installing the wallet
accessing an exchange using crypto so i
think
you know that's something that you know
if you default the boat
you know a few days maybe a couple weeks
of your time
you can become proficient enough to help
others in the process and i think
this is an industry that is like you
know if you look at the people that is
knowledgeable
at the people that in the programming
side of course
you know you have maybe ten thousand uh
you know proficient programmers in the
space so
for it for an industry that it's already
worth a trillion dollars so
i think education is a great place to
start
and also while you get educated
you know and you help others to get into
this uh
you can make a profit and find other
venues where you want to apply
so that's a very good one um and
and then i think you know to be part of
crypto you don't need to be
specializing crypto i mean you can take
whatever you do
i i that what we promoted in the early
days where there were no many places
where you could use krypton and we were
telling people
okay you can translate all money
dollars into bitcoin but something
better you can do is like offer your
services offer your products
in bitcoin and be part of the bitcoin
economy and that's the best way of being
part of this and
and you know educating yourself and
having skin in the game and starting
learning about it
yeah that's a great answer what kpis do
you think are great to assess
whether or not bitcoin is successful
this comes from daniel
uh salmon i think hey pronounce it
i i think you know when you look at the
bitcoin ecosystem
um you know and people is fixated on
transactions
per day or something like that and
bitcoin by definition has a
hard limit of maybe 700 000 transactions
per second and the protocol will evolve
very
very small very slow in that sense um
but what you have to check is is the
amount of volume
transacted because you know bitcoin is
like the core
the the core or you know settlement have
but then you have
the exchanges on top you have payment
processors so you have this
layer two you know when we talk about
layer two usually we talk about
decentralized protocols but also the the
centralized
service providers are layered to bitcoin
so
what is happening is like if you see the
amount per transaction and the volume
traded it keeps growing
in bitcoin so even the transaction the
amount of transactions
or the quantity of transactions stays
same
the volume moves through the network
keeps growing and growing and growing
and i think that's the best indicator
the of the
of the network growth and and then the
bitcoin success
yeah uh you just published our login
as open source and you'll be bringing it
to uh
taringa i think i say sam the largest
latin american social media site with 30
million users
uh talk a little bit about our login and
kind of what the impact could be
if that's adopted by more and more
companies well
um yeah at the end of 2019 we
we acquire taringa this social network
that is the
the biggest spanish-speaking social
network
and um with the aim of integrating all
the
peer-to-peer protocols all the reef
protocols into it
to turn the social network into a
fully peer-to-peer sharing economy but
the interesting thing is like
we when we say this is like we not only
want
the social aspects of the community be
managed by the users
by the community but also the economic
aspects be managed by the community
using the open finance and the
peer-to-peer protocols we are building
and also infrastructure so in the future
the idea is that
if i'm entering a user i will run the
application on my
mobile phone and i will be hosting data
for other
users so the full infrastructure
economical
uh you know social and infrastructural
elements of taringa will be run
by the community so and and again i
think this is
more current than ever with what we are
seeing around censorship in centralized
social networks because this is the
answer to to having a truly
decentralized social network and our
login is a key component because
you know we have been using um
social logins for for a while so we use
the google login or we use the facebook
login to log into other applications
and then we rely on them to revoke
access and and so we are giving away
the control to our assets our digital
assets
to third parties so the idea of our
login
is a login where you are logging in and
controlling the
the certificates the credentials to
access to any website
from your crypto wallet and we are
integrating that into taringa
so but this is only the beginning to
showcase how you can have
so when you log in into taringa you are
not relying
you won't be relying anymore on taringa
servers
the credentials will be on your wallet
the sign
the the access will be signed by your
wallet so you will be in full control of
your access
and and then you know shutting down
shutting down access to things
will be fully in your control so it's
like removing intermediation in that
point
which is one of the many points we want
to remove intermediation
yeah that's really cool uh next question
comes from
uh div x-man uh if a theorem use case as
a decentralized cloud computing grows
does the fact that 25 percent of the
ethereum network being hosted by aws
pose a risk to the ecosystem okay
yeah absolutely maybe not so much just
ethereum
and aws but just uh as decentralized
cloud computing grows
if a lot of the network is hosted on
these cloud computing centralized
entities is that a threat you know this
is all already happening there are
corporations that are not using for
example like aws
or that decided to mount around cloud
infrastructure because
they were seeing espionage from other
companies like stealing projects and
things so
i think that's a clear uh you know
point of control i mean the cloud
infrastructure
has been becoming more and more
centralized so
definitely i think that's uh that's that
can be a choke point for
for decentralized decentralized networks
as well
and there are many ways i think one
point that ethereum
uh and it was manifested recently but
was something we were very worried about
is that all the access to the blockchain
given the amount of resources that you
need to run a
node for ethereum are centralized
through
systems like infuria and those systems
are not only
working on cloud servers but also are
handled by a single organization that is
consensus
so so indeed i think decentralization
and i will say this you
we speak about decentralization as a as
a
you know discrete thing as a boolean
thing
and it's not it's like you have many
many points
many elements that need to be
decentralized to ensure that
you know we stay sobering and the
networks stay sovereign so
so i think in that sense um yeah
i think that's a that's a big problem we
have some solutions in our skate coming
like light clients so people can can you
know validate or interact with the with
the blockchain
without intermediation of third-party
services
there's a lot of things you can do also
the peer-to-peer protocols for
data sharing and secure communications
we we have something equivalent to an
incentivized store
network in the works all those things
will create like a
i would say every system can be attacked
no and then
enough but what we are doing is like
creating an imbalance where
the little guy defending from the big
guy
has an edge that that will make the big
guy
you know work to attack harder
that's about cryptography as a
asymmetric cryptography is about that no
absolutely uh next question is from uh
mira i think duron uh do you think
africa
will make a big player for crypto in the
future and
is rif rsk doing something specific for
the african market
uh the answer is yes i think you know we
are
uh trying to or working on
on making a successful model
in latin america first because that's
where we have
uh the strongest network uh you know and
and connections and we understand the
culture
deeper but definitely i think you know
africa
india southeast asia are the places
where these technologies will
will uh have its the the
the first mass mass adoption and the
reason is very simple it's like
you know it's like what happened in
africa with the they never had landlines
they went directly to the mobile phone
so
so when techno innovation comes
sometimes and you are way behind
you just leap frog to the following
stage you you don't go through all the
stages
and i think this is about that it's like
we are in in
facing we are in front of the financial
system of the future
and those regions that are lagging
behind on financial infrastructure are
not going
through the best of breed of the legacy
systems they will just
jump into this so i think africa is is a
great
and and we are doing some uh some
uh approaches in kenya in some places
but
very mild for now because you know what
we are trying to pull together
in terms of technology and option is
already challenging so
we we have the resources to go
you know for the next 10 years and go
the full process but
but we think we need to keep focus be
successful in one region and then
translate that into the different you
know
into other regions because each region
has its particularities
cultural differences so you cannot just
copycat mothers and
and that adaptation also takes time
uh i'm gonna cheat and i'm gonna ask my
own question because uh nobody's asked
this [ __ ] i thought they would
talk a little bit about lightning
network and kind of how you see that uh
being built out and kind of the
importance of it
and all of that i think lining
is is is a great extension to bitcoin
for micropayments and
you know and the more and the more it
evolves uh
you know the the the i mean the better
it works because it's about the
the liquidity put into into the payment
channels that enables the payment
channels to to work more fluidly
i i think uh we need to
supplement things like
like lighting there are payment channels
because payment channels are good to
establish
or to rebalance payments between hubs
that don't have
trust among them but you have a lot of
scenarios where
other models like relapse or what it's
called commit chains
that is the consolidation of multiple
payments in one
proof on the blockchain can have a more
more efficiency so i think what where we
are in terms of payment
uh off chain payment infrastructure is a
hybrid model where we will see
on one side things like payment chance
in lining we have the same in
in reef we have reef lumino that is the
equivalent of lining on rsk
and we are seeing that these payment
hubs or commit chains
also provide good infrastructure
solutions that
together with payment channels and
together with another protocol that we
are
implementing uh in some wallets uh
in the ecosystem called enveloping that
enables
to abstract the user from paying the
fees of the network so the
the user has experience that is closer
to a
fintech experience or a neo-bank
experience
all those three protocols are the
solutions to scale blockchains
to be able to process tens of thousand
transactions
per second in a sustainable way because
i think lining is not only about scaling
having faster payments it's also about
avoiding bloating the blockchain which
is key
because it's like when people say oh i
can do 10 000 transactions per second on
chain
that implies that you are adding like i
know maybe
20 terabytes of data per year to that
blockchain so
that instantly equates to a centralized
network
because how many people will have 20
terabytes of hardware
of other hard drives every year
to support the decentralized network so
i think you know scaling is not only
about capability
it's also about keeping the core ethos
of decentralization
that is that any human being with a
regular computer
home computer is able to download the
node and validate
the state of the network without
trusting third parties no
this connects also what we what i was
mentioning before on inferior
absolutely before we go to uh to wrap
up um i will leave a link in the uh in
the comments here in a second
for people to go to the website uh but
maybe let's just
kind of wrap up with you giving a pitch
for you know why is rsk
important why is iov important and
really
less about maybe like the specific work
you're doing but the vision that you
shared at the beginning of this which is
uh decentralized infrastructure around
bitcoin
you know why is that important and how
do we get there
well i i think you know
io labs it's just as i said we we should
be
less and less important and and what is
happening on the network should be more
and more important
we are just a mentor a sponsor of this
ecosystem
i think the real heroes are the pioneers
that are building the solutions on top
of our technology
um why rsk and reef and all the
protocols we are building
are important is like for the bitcoin
ecosystem
because we are making sure that you know
all the activity in this decentralized
networks will contribute
to to sustain the the core
infrastructure of bitcoin so um for
bitcoin is important
on two sides on one side because it
secures the sustainability of bitcoin
as the subsidy for bitcoin emission
of new car coins uh
you know is reduced this creates new
revenue streams for the bitcoin miners
for the security infrastructure so
it's important to to preserve the long
sustainability of the bitcoin ecosystem
also it's important because it provides
bitcoin with all the components needed
to have a fully decentralized and
peer-to-peer
experience for a bit coiner so you know
if you are a bitcoiner
you not only want to store value in a
decentralized platform and protect your
value your wealthiness
decentralized platform you want to live
in a truly decentralized environment
and that's what rsk and reef are
bringing and all the pioneers
in the ecosystem are bringing it truly
peer-to-peer
environment to do everything you want to
do like from financial aspects to social
aspects
to protecting your data uh so it's full
sovereignty
that's why import it's important and for
humanity because
you know we are doing this on bitcoin
for for for the reasons i mentioned
before but
our purpose is you know uh connected to
to to any human being and for humanity
because i think we are entering into a
phase
where we will have to fight for our
privacy and our sovereignty
because more and more totalitarian
models are are emerging and being used
to control
how people think uh what they do
and and how they interact with each
other and i think this fight for
sovereignty
and independence is key and also because
these technologies have
the potential of including
the half of the population that today is
completely excluded from the financial
system
and therefore you know it's doomed to be
poor forever
because they don't have the means to to
progress and
and grow and so that's why i think this
is so relevant and
that's why we're doing what we do i am
uh i'm a big fan
i think that not only is bitcoin
probably one of the most important
inventions
uh in the past 20 30 years but obviously
it is going to be
crucial that there is this element of
non-censorship
and security and privacy and so
decentralized infrastructure is kind of
a no-brainer and you guys have been
doing some fantastic work
so listen i think for i speak for
everyone who's uh who's watching this
uh thank you so much for uh for joining
us if you are
watching live right now make sure that
you smash the like button as we end so
that more people on youtube will see
this
make sure you are subscribed to the
channel and then if you want to learn
more about iov
labs and rsk you can go to rsk.co
openfinance but thank you guys so much
for joining
diego you are an absolute legend and i
appreciate all the hard work you guys
have been doing
and we will have to do this again in the
future my friend thank you anthony it
will be my pleasure and
and also thank you for all the work you
do
spreading the word very important